well tourism is what keeps our city
going and governor sisolak is making
sure those that work with visitors
directly are
safe thank you for joining us at 11 i'm
brian loftis
valdez the governor paying a visit to
one of the largest vaccination sites on
the strip today
as our city begins its economic rebound
sasha loftis joins us live from las
vegas boulevard tonight with how those
workers feel about getting support from
state leaders
sasha denise and bryan governor says
elect says a safer nevada really does
start with those
here in the hospitality industry i spoke
with one hotel owner tonight who says
she's grateful to have this protection
after a tough
few months make me feel more secure
in my job after a year of ups and downs
delia garcia describes the peace of mind
that comes with the covid19 vaccine we
never expect
to be in this position so scary you know
to open
one door in the in the rooms she's a
guest room attendant at delano las vegas
and one of about 5 000 who got her shot
here
at mgm's employee vaccination clinic
work being done here is tremendous
governor steve siselek made a stop at
the site thursday
to tout the importance of protecting our
community's
front line workers the nevada experience
that visitors from around the globe
enjoy so much
would not be possible without the men
and women
that are part of our hospitality
industry officials say over 100 thousand
in the industry have received their
shots
with our state's largest gaming
operators reporting a 60 to
70 percent vaccination rate in order to
protect the industry which is the
primary charge of the gaming control
board we had to protect the workers
it's an effort many call crucial to our
community's rebound
and garcia says she's grateful to be a
part of it
you have to think in your family and
your coworkers
and selling yourself
the governor says that our gaming
industry across the state has
25 different pop-up vaccination sites
that are available at the moment he also
added
that large companies like mgm and
caesars entertainment will be adding
more pop-up vaccination sites to reach
everyone
in the coming weeks and months reporting
live from the las vegas strip tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now